All right. Hi everyone. Okay, I guess we're live.
Ah, so as- as- Aarti was saying,
please enter your SUNetID.
Ah, we can bring this up again at the end of class today.
We'll just take another like, what 20 seconds?
And then we'll- we'll go on to the main discussion.
[NOISE] All right.
So, um, what I want to discuss with you today is,
um, ah, what I'm going to call full cycle deep learning applications, right?
Um, [NOISE] and so,
um, I think this Sunday, uh,
you'll be submitting your proposals for the,
ah, class projects you do this quarter.
And, um, in most of the, uh,
in- in a lot of what you learn about the machine learning projects,
you learn how to build machine learning models.
Um, what I want to do today is share with you
the bigger context of how a machine learning model,
you know, how a neural network you might train, uh,
fits in the context of a bigger project.
Uh, so what are all the steps, right?
Just as if you're writing a software product,
you know, you take another classes,
then you, uh, what happened?
That, uh, they teach you how to build a website for example.
What is that? Um, but
to build a product requires more than just building a website, right?
So, what are the- what are the other things you need to do to
actually do a successful software project?
And in this case, to do a successful machine learning application.
Um, and so, uh,
let's see. So- so, yeah.
Test, test, is the audio on?
Test. Could you turn up the audio?
Yeah, how is this?
No? Can't here me now.
Hey.
Oh, I think I'm broadcasting.
I hear myself great.
[LAUGHTER] Okay, you can hear me now.
Great. Thank you. All right. Thank you. All right.
So, what I want to do is share with you,
um, full cycle machine learning.
Not just how to, uh,
you learn a lot about how to build deep learning models
but how does that fit in a bigger project, right?
Just as if you're taking the class on building a website,
you know, then great, you know how the code of a website, that's really valuable.
But what are all the things you need to do to make a successful website?
Or to build a- build a project that
involves launching a website or mobile app or whatever.
Um, so as- as you plan for your,
um, class project proposals, uh,
due this Sunday, uh,
if you're doing an application project that fits in the context of a bigger application,
um, also keep all these steps in mind, right?
So, um, you know,
these are what I think of as the steps of an ML project,
or really maybe- maybe not fast project but
maybe a serious machine learning application, right?
And I think, oh, no I built a lot of machine learning products over several years.
So, some of these are also things that I wish I had known,
you know, many years ago.
Um, one, does this kind of- maybe kind of obvious but,
you know, select a problem.
And let's say for the sake of simplicity data,
you use supervised learning, right.
It- it turns out for the CS 230 class projects I think,
uh, more than 50 percent of the class projects tend to use supervised learning.
There are also other projects that use- end up
using GANs which we'll talk about later this quarter or other things.
But I think, you know,
let's say you use supervised learning to- to build interesting application.
Um, and- and I think for today,
I'm going to use as a running example of building a,
um, building a- a voice-activated device, right?
So, you know, uh, no, actually,
how- how many of you have like a smart speaker in your home?
Like a voice-activated device in your home?
You know, the- in- in the US?
Well, not that many of you, interesting. Okay cool.
Yeah, so, I think, uh, you know the- the Amazon Echos, Google Homes,
the Apple Siris or the- the- in- in China,
my- one of former team's built Baidu DeurOS.
Ah, ah but let's say for the sake of
argument that you want to build a voice-activated device.
And I'm going to use as a running example.
Um, and so in order to build a voice-activated device,
and- and again I'm not going to use any of
the commercial brands like Alexa or OK Google or Hey Siri
or I guess in China it was a Hello [FOREIGN] which means kind of roughly hello little du.
Um, but let's use a more neutral word which as I see you
wanted to build a device that your responsive word activate.
Um, and you're actually going to implement this as a problem set later this quarter.
Um, but so you want to build a yeah.
Is it possible to [inaudible].
Okay. No. Volume up.
Uh, uh, let's see how that- okay is this better?
No? Yes? No? This is better?
Okay, cool. Thank you. Look at how ironic,
talk about speech recognition and the volume isn't high enough.
Okay. um, so let's say you want- well,
[LAUGHTER] let me know about comes off again and thank you.
Okay. Um, so let's say you want to build a voice-activated device.
So, the key components,
the key machine learning,
deep learning component is going to be a learning algorithm
that takes as input an audio clip and,
uh, outputs, um, did it detect what's sometimes called the trigger word.
Did I go soft again? Okay, this is okay, great.
All right and- and O plus Y,
you know zero one,
they did detect their trigger word such as Alexa,
or OK Google or Hey Siri,
or Hello [inaudible] or, um,
or activate or whatever wake word or trigger word, right?
Um, and so step one is,
uh, select a problem.
Um, and then, in order to train a learning algorithm,
you need to get labeled data if you're applying supervised learning.
And then you design a model,
use back prop or some of the other algorithms you learned about momentum,
Adam, so you know, this optimization algorithms gradient descend,
to train the model.
Um, and then maybe you test it on your test set.
And then you deploy it meaning you start selling these smart speakers and,
you know, putting them into hopefully into your users homes.
Um, and then you have to maintain the system.
I'll talk about this later as well.
Uh, and- and this is not chronological but, ah,
one thing that's often done,
but I- I want to talk about it at the end instead is not really step eight.
It's a QA which is, uh,
quality assurance which is an ongoing process, right?
And so, um, one, uh, let's see.
So, as you- so if you want to build a product,
if you want to sell a machine learning product,
these are maybe some of the key steps you need to work on.
Um, some observations, when you train a model,
training a model is often a very iterative process.
So, every time we train the machine learning model,
you'll find that, you know,
I can almost guarantee whatever you do,
it will not work.
At least not the first time, right?
And so you'll find that even though I've written these, uh, sequence of steps,
when you train a model, you undergo,
no- that neural network architecture didn't work.
and need to increase the number of hidden units or change the regularization
or switch to RNN or switch to a totally different architecture.
And sometimes you train a model and go nope, that didn't work.
Um, I need to get more data, right?
And so this is often a very iterative process we are cycling through,
um, uh, the several different steps here.
Um, and then I think, ah,
one distinction that you have not yet learned about in the Coursera- in
the deeplearning.ai Coursera videos is how to
split up the data into train, dev, and tests.
So, I am going to simplify those details for now.
But just as a- a foreshadowing I guess of what,
um, you learn later in the- in the, uh,
deeplearning.ai Coursera videos is how to take a data set,
you have trained into- excuse me,
into a training set, um,
ah, into a set that you actually test cross-validate
using during development called the dev set or development set
or [inaudible] cross validation set.
That was a separate test set.
So, you'll learn about this later.
But I'm just simplifying a little bit, um, for today.
Okay. So, um, so I think,
um, the first thing I want to do is ask you a question, right?
So, we're going to talk through many of these steps.
And when it turns out that, um,
what a lot of machine learning classes do and- and do a good job teaching
is focusing on maybe these three steps,
or maybe these four steps, right?
And what I want to do today is spend more time,
so this is the heart of machine learning,
how do you build a great model.
Uh, and what I want to do today is spend more time talking about step one,
uh, and six and seven,
and then just a little bit of time talking about
the core of this because you kind of need to do
the other steps as well when you want build
a deep learning product or build a machine learning application.
Okay. Um, so let's talk about discussion question.
Um, I'm actually curious.
Uh, if you're selecting a, um,
project to work on, uh,
uh, what are the- actually so I- don't- don't answer this yet.
I'll- I'll tell you what the question I'm going to ask is,
um, which is- [NOISE]
All right. Uh, what properties make for a good candidate deep learning project?
But don't answer yet, right?
So I, I wanna say a few more things before,
before I invite you to answer,
which is that, um,
all of you, for the last few days,
I hope, have been thinking about what project you wanna do for this class.
And what I wanna do is just discuss some properties of what are
good projects to work on and what are maybe not good projects to work on, okay?
And, and think of this as your chance to give your classmates advice, right?
What are the things your classmates should think about if they can't
decide this is a good project to work on, okay?
Um, and so, what I wanna do for today is, ah,
use, um, this voice-activated thing as a mo- as a,
as a motivating example.
And, you know, th- there's actually one project I, uh,
uh, was working on,
uh, the, the, actually,
I thought, there were, actually, there's one project I thought of
working on but decided not to work on,
ah, and that, that, that's a voice-activated device.
So, it turns out that [NOISE] , um,
these voice-activated devices like Echo, Google Homes, and so on,
they are taking off quite rapidly in the US and around the world.
Um, it turns out that one of the, you know,
significant pain points of these devices is the need to,
um, configure it, right?
To set it up for Wi-Fi.
So, um, I've done a lot of work on speech recognition, you know, ah,
a hotel, did a lot of work on group speech system,
I led the Baidu speech system.
So I've been published papers on speech recognition,
and I have a, I have one of these devices in my home, right?
Um, well, a- actually, Amazon, I have an Amazon Echo in my living room.
Um, but even to this day,
I have configured exactly one light bulb to be hooked up,
to be controlled by my Echo,
[LAUGHTER] because the, the seller process,
not blaming any country,
it's just difficult to hook up, you know,
a Wi-Fi enabled light bulb and then to
set it up so that your s- smart speaker or whatever,
as in, say, you know, "Smart device, turn off the lamp."
So, I, I have one light bulb in my living room where,
that I can [LAUGHTER] turn on and off and that's it, right?
[LAUGHTER] Ah, even as a speech researcher.
So, [LAUGHTER] um, maybe that's even a bad example.
Um, so one, one,
one application that I think, ah,
that the, I, I was actually searching because you're working on is to build a, um,
embedded device that you can sell to lamp makers,
so that, I don't know where you buy your lamps from, but, you know,
I have a few lamps from IKEA,
or a few lamps from wherever.
But you can buy a desk lamp,
[NOISE] so that when you buy the desk lamp,
there's already a built-in microphone,
so that without needing to connect this thing to Wi-Fi, you know, and say,
"Hey here's a $20 desk lamp, um,
put them on your desk," and you can go home and say,
"Desk lamp, turn on,
or desk lamp, turn off."
Uh, then, I think that will help a lot more
users get voice-activated devices into their home.
And it's actually not clear to me,
if you want to turn on a desk lamp,
it's actually not clear to me that you want to turn to a smart speaker and say,
"Hey, Smart Speaker, please turn on that lamp over there," right?
I- it, it, maybe it feels more natural to just talk
directly to a desk lamp and tell it to turn on and turn off.
Um, and so, ah, a- also for what it's worth,
someone we're friends now with evaluated this,
we actually thought that this could be a r- reasonable business,
to build embedded devices,
to sell to lamp makers or other device makers so that they can sell
their own voice-activated devices without needing this complicated Wi-Fi setup process.
Um, and so to do this,
you would need to build a learning algorithm,
and have it run on an embedded device,
then it just inputs an audio clip and outputs,
you know, whenever it detects the, the, the wake word.
And instead of a wake word being "Activate," the wake word would be a "Lamp,
turn on" or "Lamp, turn off."
You need two wake words or trigger words,
one to turn it on, one to turn it off, right?
Oh, and, and, and, and I think just the other thing that,
um, I think would make this work,
ah, is, um, ah, ah, to, ah,
to give these devices names.
So, if you have five lamps, or two lamps, you,
you need an wait index into these different desk lamps.
So, um, let's say you decide for your project,
you know, to have a little switch here,
so this lamp could be called John,
[NOISE] or Mary, or Bob,
or Alice, like a four-way switch.
So that's depending on where you set this four-way switch, you can say,
you know, "John," right?
"Turn on," right?
O- or d- if, if you decide to call this lamp John,
I guess you could give some other names so you don't have
any lamp by the same name, okay?
Um, so, what I'm gonna do is use as a, ah,
motivating example on this as a possible project.
Oh, and, and I'm not working on this.
If any of you want to build a startup doing this,
go for it, I, I, this is not net, [NOISE] well,
I, I felt my teams and I, we had better ideas,
so we wanted to do other things in this
but I actually don't see anything wrong with this.
I think this actually could be a reasonable thing
to pursue as well, but I'm not doing it.
So you're all very welcome to, if you want, okay?
[NOISE] Um, so now,
the question I want to pose to you [NOISE] is, ah,
when you're brainstorming project ideas, you know, like, this idea,
or some other idea, um,
what are the things you would want to watch out for?
Wha- what are the properties that you would want to be true
in order for you to feel good proposing this as a,
as a CS 230 Project, right?
So why don't you take a minute and, and write this down.
I think, ah, uh, uh, yeah.
Well, wha- wha- what if, if you're asking a friend if, if a friend is asking you,
"What are the things I should look at to see if something is [NOISE] a good project?"
What would you, what would you recommend to them?
So, fe- few, just write down a few key words,
and then we'll see what people say.
And then, and then, I'll tell you what I tend to
look out for when I'm selecting projects.
And I have a list of, ah, five points.
Might take like, I don't know,
like, two minutes to-
That's not activated.
Yeah.
Oh. Sorry. This is not activated?
Um, uh, you're not able to answer this up, enter answers?
Okay. [NOISE] Let me test the Internet access.
Just, [NOISE] just checking it.
Yeah. I'm connected to the Internet.
Uh, [NOISE] Aarti, any ideas?
[NOISE]
It was just activated.
Oh, I see. Okay. All right.
Let me try that. [NOISE] I'll just.
Turn it on. [OVERLAPPING]
Oh, it's working now? Okay. Thank you. [OVERLAPPING]
Maybe I'll turn off to do it,
but it keeps getting turning off.
Okay. Yes. Thank you.
[NOISE]
Yeah.
Thanks.
[NOISE] So, if you take,
like, two minutes to enter, and I think,
I think I can figure this and let you enter multiple answers.
Let me just take two minutes.
[NOISE]
All right, another one minute.
All right, 30 seconds.
Okay, three, two, one.
Well, maybe in the hindsight that wasn't the best visualization.
Can people see this?
[NOISE]
Um nevermind, trying to see if- all right so,
data novelty, loss of data,
some of these are very small, human doable,
number of examples, do one,
two ones [inaudible] algorithm,
new industry of fields, uh,
clear objective, practical useful, huh,
oh, finishing time, uh, [LAUGHTER].
Host real life problem,
useful hasn't been done [inaudible] tractable.
Yeah. Generalization [inaudible] Um,
let me make some comments on these.
I think I, this is,
this is pretty good, um.
I have a list of five bullet points and maybe I just share
of you my list of five, uh, um,
[NOISE] which is I'm,
just some things to encourage you to pay attention to, um, you know.
This, this may or may not be the best criteria,
but interests I think, well,
interests plus, uh, I just hopefully you
work on something that you're actually interested in, um.
And then I think, uh, uh, right,
data availability which many of you cited is a good criteria or,
uh, wanted the ways that,
um, Stanford class projects sometimes do not go well,
is its students spend a month trying to collect data and after month
have not yet found the data and then- and then,
you know, and then there's uh,
and then there's a lot of wasted time.
Um, one thing that I would encourage
you to consider as well is,
uh, domain knowledge, um.
And I think that if you are a biologist and have
unique knowledge into some aspect of
biology through which you want to apply Machine learning,
that will actually let you do a very interesting project, right.
That- that is is actually difficult for others to do.
Um, and I think, uh,
more generally as, as a advice for navigating your careers, right.
So, you know, i- its interesting because you know,
Machine learning, Deep learning, there's so much,
there's so many people wanting to jump into Machine learning and Deep learning,
um, actually I'll give you an example.
So, I sometimes talk to, uh, uh, doctors,
Radiology students, uh, uh, including, you know,
like Stanford and other universities
Radiology students that want to learn about Machine learning, right?
Because they hear about, you know, Deep learning,
maybe someday affecting radiologist jobs,
and so they want to be part of Deep learning.
And so my career advice to them is usually
to not forget everything they learned as a doctor and try to,
you know, do Machine learning 101 from scratch and just
forget everything they learned as a doctor and just become a CS major.
I think that- that path can work,
but I think where radiologists could do the most unique work,
uh, that allows them to make a most unique contribution,
is that they use their domain knowledge of
healthcare radiology and do something in Machine learning applied to radiology,
right, uh, and so,
was [LAUGHTER] all right.
[LAUGHTER] How, how many- how many millennials are there in this class?
[LAUGHTER] What is that me,
me, me, me, me thing? [LAUGHTER] All right.
All right. This is really wrong.
Yeah. [LAUGHTER] I- I think it's because this is a word cloud.
So they count word frequency,
right? The money thing.
I don't know, I have very mixed feelings about that [LAUGHTER]. All right.
Um, but I think as,
[inaudible] I actually know that some of you are taking, you know,
Deep learning because you work in a different discipline and
you want to do something in this hot, new,
exciting thing of Machine learning and I think,
uh, whatever this major you're in,
if your domain knowledge about some other area,
you know, Education, Civil Engineering, Biology, Law.
Um, taking Deep learning allows you to do
very unique work applying Machine learning to your domain,
right, um, [NOISE] uh. Let's see.
Um, I think that, uh,
uh, um, [NOISE] um,
I think, well, I call the utility but several of you mentioned as well,
something that has a positive impact that actually helps other people,
uh, uh, uh, and,
and I- I- I don't know money could be an aspect of utility,
but maybe not, the most inspiring one uh,
and then I think, um,
[NOISE] and I think one of the biggest challenges we face in the industry today is still,
frankly, is actually good judgment on feasibility, um.
So today, I still see too many, uh, leaders,
sometimes CEOs of large companies that stand
on stage and announce to the whole world, you know,
we're gonna do this Machine learning project,
to do this by this deadline and then 20 minutes later,
I talk to their engineers and the engineers say nope, no way,
not happening what the [LAUGHTER] CEO just finally says [LAUGHTER]
whole engineering [inaudible] is not doing that and knows that it's impossible.
So, I think one of the biggest challenges is actually feasibility um,
in fact, I actually know that's a- a- a you know,
I was chatting with Aarti about, uh, the, the,
um, uh TA office hours and I know that, uh,
uh there been lot of,
you know, a lot of you have been, uh,
thinking about applying, uh,
end-to-end Deep learning, right?
You know. Can you input any x and output any y and
do that accurately and sometimes it's possible and sometimes it's not,
and it still takes, uh, relatively deep,
deep judgment about what neural networks can and cannot do with a certain amount of
data that you may or may not be able to
acquire in order to do some of these things, right?
Um, so- so, I think throughout this quarter,
you gain much deeper judgment as well on on what is feasible, I guess.
[NOISE] This is pretty interesting.
I once know, uh, uh, uh I- I- I knew a CEO of a ve- very,
of a large company that once told his team,
um, uh, he actually gave this team these instructions.
He said, uh, I wish they assume that AI can do anything,
uh, and- and- and uh, uh,
I think tha- tha- that had an interesting effect, I guess.
Uh, uh, uh, yeah.
Cool. All right.
So, I think step one, um,
was select a project,
I hope this is [inaudible] projects,
try to keep some of those things in mind, um.
Step two is get data, right, [NOISE] um.
And so, uh, what I want you to do,
uh, and I'm going to pose the second question
and then have some you discuss this.
Let's say that you're actually working on this, you know,
smarts voice-activated embedded devices thing, right?
So let's say that you and your friends wanna build a start up so
train a deep learning algorithm to detect, you know,
phrases like John turned on or Mary turn off or Bob turn off or whatever, uh,
to sell to device makers so that they
can have low voice [NOISE] embedded voice detection chip.
It doesn't require a complicated Wi-Fi setup process, right?
So let's see one of- let's see how she wanna do this.
So, you need to collect some data in order
to start training a learning algorithm, all right?
So, uh, the second question I would pose to you is, uh, uh,
uh, two- a question in two parts uh,
but, but, uh, have you answer it all,
all at the same time which is,
uh, in how many, how many days,
let's say you actually proposed this for
your CS 230 project this Sunday and then you start work on it,
you know, like on Monday.
Are you guys start work on it today before the proposal?
But, uh, how many days would you spend collecting data?
Uh, and how would you collect data?
Okay? And I think, um, I'm actually how,
how many of you have participated in Engineering Scrum?
If you know what that means?
Okay a few of you uh, those who have an industry.
Okay, all right so engineering estimation,
when you estimate how long a project takes one of the common practices is
use a Fibonacci sequence to estimate how long a project will take, right?
And so Fibonacci sequence one, one, two,
three, five, eight,13 and so on.
And this roughly powers of two- but doesn't grow as fast as
powers to Fibonacci numbers are cool, right.
For so- uh, uh, so,
so what I want you to do is just finish after configuration right.
When our, um, speech bubbles, okay.
Yeah, that's good. All right.
So what I'd like you to do is in the text answer,
uh, I really write two things,
one is write a number,
how many days do you think you spent on collecting data?
You and your teammates if you're actually doing this project.
Uh, and then how,
how would you go about collecting the data?
Okay? So once you take good, another two minutes,
uh, to write in an answer.
[NOISE] Oh I'm sorry.
This heavy load, now still not activated.
So then try to hit, uh, interesting.
That is not helpful.
All right, that is definitely not helpful.
Um. All right, let's do this,
write down your answer on a piece of paper first and take two minutes [inaudible 29:10].
So the two questions are,
are how many days?
Uh, pick a number from a Fibonacci sequence and,
uh, are you going to use it nothing?
Oh, okay, uh, let's swap out my computer for Aarti's.
Oh actually, yeah oh,
if Aarti's computers working, actually go ahead.
Sorry. Okay I can just present.
Yeah, yeah let's, let's plug in your laptop? Shall we?
So you just use your laptop. [NOISE] See, sure.
Yeah. Yeah. Doesn't say I wonder if there's a network problem or web browser problem.
Uh, I started using uh,
Firefox recently in addition to Chrome and Safari and that was Firefox,
I've tried with other web browsers later.
Right, cool. Okay, okay, thank you.
Thanks all to you. [NOISE].
All right. I can maybe,
yeah maybe people then take another minute from now,
just extend the time a bit to end.
All right. Now the 10 seconds.
All right, cool. Let's see,
uh, show people's answers, okay?
Right. Well, three hundred sixty-five
So, there's a, there's a,
there's a lot of variance in the answers, right?
Uh, [LAUGHTER] Download from online depends on what data you want.
It turns out well.
So if you're trying to find data or phrases like John turn on that,
that, that data doesn't exist online.
Uh, it turns out that we're trying to find audio clips at the web activate.
There are some websites with, uh,
single words pronounce but those- but uh,
not a lot of audio clips session so
the trigger world where the wake word is the word activate.
Uh, there are some websites we can download like,
maybe 10 audio clips of a few people saying activate but it's quite
hard to find hundreds of examples of different people saying the word activate.
Um.
Five days it falls from the sky.
[LAUGHTER] All right, so,
let me suggest, um,
uh- let me suggest that you guys discuss with each other in small groups,
uh, what you think would be the best strategy?
How many days we find collecting the data and how we decide collecting data?
Try convince people next to you on that.
Uh, and, and before I ask you to start discussing,
I wanna leave you with one thought which is, um,
how long do you think will take you to train your first model?
Right. And so if it take you a day to train your first model or two days?
Uh, do you want to spend x time collecting data and then spend let's say,
you know, I'll know to [inaudible] the deep learning thing,
train a model, it might take a couple of days, right?
Especially if you've download open source packages, so,
so the amount of time needed to collect data as
x followed by two days to train your first model,
what do you think x should be the amount of time?
Once you go spend like two minutes to discuss with each
other and see if you can, can the, the,
the answers are- there is
very large variance right once you guys discuss, if you actually, if,
if the people sitting next to you are your project partners,
why should you discuss with them how,
how many days you think you should spend collecting data and how you collect the data?
Okay? Why don't you  take two minutes to discuss a little.
[NOISE]
All right.
[NOISE] All right guys.
So, [NOISE] wow, all right guys.
[LAUGHTER] Hey guys.
So, [NOISE] all right.
A lot of exciting discussion.
So, actually how, how many of you,
how many of the groups wound up on the, on the low end?
How many of you, you know,
convinced each other that maybe it should be,
like, three days or less?
Oh, just a few of you. How come?
Some, some- someone, someone say why?
Why is it, why, why?
Because you wanted us to see if the algorithm works first.
So, we need some direction to just test to see if the algorithm is even reaching
some sort of good benchmark before we then go and collect the next data set.
Cool, yeah, right. I guess a little bit of data to test how
the algorithm works before you even go and collect the next data set, all right?
Cool. And did anyone had a,
had a high-end, like a 13 days or more?Yes.
Very few. How come?
Anyone, actually anyone, anyone with
insights you want to share with the whole class if you,
what, what were you all discussing so excitedly?
[LAUGHTER]. Yeah, go ahead.
So, um, depending on domain knowledge, uh,
maybe a connection can take a long time especially for this problem,
like, based on that one idea which we discussed in previous class, we were thinking like,
we could use like, movie clips and like,
some typos to like, generate sound like,
[inaudible] And that will take like time to like
mine data, um, [inaudible] [NOISE],
Yeah, yeah, yeah, right.
Yeah. So, there are accompanying systems to look at subtitle,
uh, uh, videos, right?
Uh, uh, like, uh,
YouTube videos with captions or something and,
and if there's, uh, appropriately,
creative commons data there you can use.
Yeah. So, let me,
let me tell you my bias.
I, I- I'll just tell you what I would do if I was working on this project.
Well, as, well, one caveat,
I haven't done so much work in speech recognition previously, right?
This is my first project.
Um, I would probably spend 1-2 days collecting data [NOISE],
kind of, on the short end, right?
And I think that, you know, one of the,
and, and, and one of the reasons is that Machine Learning,
kind of that circle I drew up there is actually a very iterative process where,
um, until you try it, you,
you almost never know what's actually going to be hard about the problem, right?
And so, um, so if I was doing this project,
I'll just tell you honestly what I would do.
Like, again, I've actually thought about this project a bunch, right?
Including, you know, trying to validate market acceptance and so on.
But, um, but which is that, um,
I would get a cheap microphone, a user or,
or user built-in laptop microphone or buy a microphone off, you know,
buy a microphone off Amazon or something and go around say,
go around Stanford campus or go to your friends and have them just say, "Hey,
do you mind saying into this microphone the word activate or John,
turn on or whatever," and collect a bunch of data that way.
Um, and then, uh,
uh, and with one or two days, um,
you should be able to collect at least hundreds of examples, uh,
and that might be enough of the data set to start
training a rudimentary learning algorithm to get going.
Because if you have not yet worked on this problem before,
it turns out to be very difficult to know what's going to be hard about the problem.
So, is what's gonna be hard, um,
highly accented speakers, right?
Uh, or is what's gonna be hard background noise, um,
or is what's gonna be hard, you know,
confusing turn on with turn off?
You hear John turn and then [NOISE] But when you build a new Machine Learning system,
it's very difficult to know what's hard and what's easy about the problem, uh,
or or is what's gonna be difficult that far-field, which is,
um, the technical term for if the microphone is very far away, right?
So, it turns out that, you know,
if, if we turn on the, um,
microphone on my laptop now for example,
um, the, the laptop,
which is what, like three meters away from me, uh,
will be hearing voice directly from my mouth as well as voice bouncing off the walls.
[NOISE] So, there's a lot of reverberation in this room
and so that makes speech recognition harder.
You, me are so good at processing out reverberant sounds,
reverberations that you almost don't notice it,
but it may, i- it actually the,
but the learning algorithm will have,
sometimes has problems with reverberations, right?
Or echos bouncing off the hard walls of this room.
Um, and so depending on what your learning algorithm has trouble with,
um, you will then want to go back to collect
very different types of data or explore very different types of algorithms.
Well, the problem is that sometimes is because just the volume is just too soft,
in which case, you know, maybe you need to do
something else and normalize all your volumes,
or buy a more sensitive microphone or something.
So, it turns out that when building most Machine Learning applications,
unless you've experienced working on it.
So, I- I've actually worked on this problem before,
so I have a sense of what's hard and what's easy.
But when you work on a new project for the first time,
it's very difficult to know what's hard and what's easy.
And so my advice to most teams is, um,
rather than [NOISE] spending say
20 days to collect data and then two days to collect model,
to train a model,
and it's often by training a model and then seeing what are the examples it gets wrong,
when does the algorithm fail?
That, that, that's your feedback to either collect
more data or redesign the model, right?
Or try something else.
Um, and if you can shrink the data collection period
down to be more comparable to how long you end up taking to train your model,
then you can start iterating much more rapidly on,
on actually improving your model, right?
Uh, and uh, so maybe one rule of
thumb I actually tend to recommend for most class projects is I know,
if i- maybe if you need to spend a week,
up to a week to collect data, you know,
maybe that's okay, but if you can get it going even more quickly.
Uh, uh, I would even maybe more strongly recommend that, um,
and there have been so few examples in
my life where the first time I trained a learning algorithm it worked, right?
I- it like, pretty much never happens.
Yeah, I, I, I, i- it happened once about a year ago and I was so surprised,
I still remember that one time.
[LAUGHTER] Uh, and so what, so,
so Machine Learning development is often
a very iterative process and by quickly collecting data set.
And, and often data sets are collected through sweat and hard work, right?
And so, I, I would literally,
you know, and actually,
well, I've actually done a long long speech.
And to get it going quickly,
I would probably just, um, uh,
have myself or my team members run around and find
people and ask them to speak into a microphone and record audio clips that way.
Um, and then only when you validate that you need
a bigger data set would you go to a more complicated things,
like set up an Amazon Mechanical Turk thing, right?
To crowdsource, which I've also done actually, right?
I also had very large data sets collected off Amazon Mechanical Turk,
but only in a later stage of the project where you
understand what you really need, right?
Um, so as you,
as you start working on your class projects,
maybe, maybe keep that, keep that in mind.
So, now, um, [NOISE] so,
one other tip that,
uh, Machine Learning researchers,
on average, we tend to be terrible at this,
um, um, but I'll give this advice anyway,
is when you're going through this process,
getting data, design a model, uh,
a literature search would be very helpful, you know,
so see what other, see what algorithms others are using for this problem.
It turns out the literature is actually quite immature.
There isn't a convergence of,
uh, like a world standard set,
sta- standard algorithms for trigger word detection in literature right now,
which people are still making up algorithms.
So, if you, if you do a little survey,
you find that to be the case,
but you're training initial model.
Um, and in most Machine Learning applications,
you go through this process multiple times.
So, one tip that I would recommend you do is, uh,
keep clear notes, um, on the experiments you've run.
Right. Because they'll often be as you train the model,
you see oh this model works great on American accent of speakers,
but not on British accent of speakers.
Right. I- I- I was born in the UK,
sometimes I use British accents for example.
If you are from a different part of the world,
you think of different global accents but since I'm from the UK,
I'm- I'm just gonna pick on British accents I guess.
Keep clear notes on the experiments run because what happens in
every machine learning project is after awhile you
have trained 30 models and then you and your team members are going,
"Oh yeah, we tried that idea two weeks ago did it work and if you have
clear notes from when you actually did that work two weeks ago,
then you can refer back rather than have to rerun the experiments."
Um, the other thing that some groups do is, um,
have a spreadsheet that keeps track of what's the learning rate you use?
What's the number of hidden units?
What's this? What's this? What's this?
Or, or, or, or cheaper than a,
than a text document so that which will make it easier to refer back to,
to know someone's you tried earlier.
Um, this is one piece of commonly-given advice.
This is one of those things that
every machine learning person knows we should do this but on average,
we're very bad at doing this but,
but, but, but, but you could I don't know.
But at the times, I've managed to keep good notes so that you save them
all the time right to try to remember what exactly you tried two weeks ago.
Okay. So, a lot of this class will be on this process of how to get data,
develop the train data test the design the model, train the model.
Eventually, test them all then iterate.
Okay. So, a lot this classes on this.
So, I wanna jump ahead. So, when you have a good enough model and you want to deploy it.
Okay. So, step six,
I guess is deployment.
Now, um, um, this is er, uh, um,
one of the reasons I want to step through
this example going through a concrete example is
I find that when you're learning about machine
learning for the first time is often seeing,
you know, what- what my team says called war stories
kinda of stories or projects that, that,
that others have built before that often provides the best learning experience.
I think like I have built speech recognition systems.
It took me like a year or two years for me to do it.
So, I'm trying to so rather than, you know,
having you spend two years of your life building
speech systems and can summarize a war story.
Right. To tell you what the process is like,
I'm hoping that these concrete examples of what building these systems are like in,
you know, large corporations that can help you accelerate
your learnings without needing to get two years of on-the-job experience.
You can just secure the salient points.
Okay. Now, if you're deploying a system like this,
one of the things, um, and this is actually true.
This is actually a real phenomenon for deploying
speech systems is you have the audio clip,
you have a neural network,
and then you know this will output zero,
one and the neural networks that work well,
will tend to be relatively large,
right relatively large model.
Larger than hidden units relatively high complexity.
And, um, if you have some of the smart speakers in your home, um,
you recognize that a lot of them are Edge devices as
opposed to purely cloud computation, right?
So we all know what the cloud is.
Um, uh, and what an Edge device is.
And Edge device is a smart speaker that's in your home or the cell phone in your wallet.
So, Edge devices are you know the things that are close to
the data as opposed to the cloud which is
a giant service we have in our data centers, right?
So, um, because of network latency,
er, er, and, and,
and because of privacy a lot of these computations are
done on Edge devices like a smart speaker in your home or,
er, er, like er, I guess Hey Siri or Okay Google can wake up your cell phone, right?
And so, Edge devices have much lower computational budgets and much lower power budgets,
limited battery life, much less powerful processes
than we have in our cloud data centers.
And so, it turns out that se- se
serving up a very large neural network is quite difficult.
Right? It's very difficult for,
you know, a low-power,
inexpensive microprocessor sitting on a smart speaking in your living room
to run a very large neural network with a lot of hidden units and a lot parameters.
And so, what is often done is to actually do this.
Which is to input an audio clip and then have a much simpler algorithm.
Uh, figure out if, you know,
anyone is even talking, right?
Because so the smart speaker, you know,
in my living room hears silence most of the day, right?
Because usually, just no one at home, right?
There's no no voice.
And then only if it hears, you know,
someone talking then feed it to the big neural network that you've trained and ramp-up,
use a larger power budget in order to classify 01.
Okay. Um, this component goes by many different names, um,
in- in reasonably standard terminology but not totally standard terminology.
The literature I'm gonna call this VAD.
For- Voice Activity Detection.
[NOISE] Right.
Um, it turns out that voice activity detection,
there's a standard component is in
many different speech recognition systems if you are using a cellphone for example,
VAD is a component that tries to figure out if anyone's even talking because if they think
no one is talking then there's no need to encode the audio and try to transmit the audio,
right? Aarti, could you?
Okay.
Yeah. [LAUGHTER] Yeah. Um, and so,
uh, so the next question I want to ask you and,
and I- I- I thought this is timely because, um, uh,
well there's a couple options, right?
Option one is to build a non-machine learning-based VAD system,
Voice Activity Detection system which is just, you know,
see if the volume
of the audio your smart speaker is recording is greater than epsilon.
So, the silence just forget it.
And option two is train a small neural network, um,
to recognize on, on,
on human speech, right?
And so, uh, my next question to you is,
um, if you're working on this project,
would you pick option one or would you pick option two?
Right? As you, as you,
as you move toward- oh sorry and I think,
um, a small neural network.
So, a small neural network or in some cases,
I've seen people use a small support vector machine
as well for those who don't know what that is.
A small model can be run with a low computational budget.
There's a much simpler problem to detect if someone is talking than to
recognize a word they said so you can actually do this, you know,
but this with reasonable accuracy with a small neural network but if you actually work on
this project for CS 230 which would you try first?
So, could we come to the next question?
Yes.
Okay.
I cant figure out how to do that.
Oh oh sure.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you can let them
start answering I guess and then while you figure out the projection.
Cool.
I will just keep unlocking it periodically.
Are people able to vote?
No, there are no votes yet.
Well, I guess you write so much code,
you have a shortcut to go so you're coding environment on your laptop. Great. [LAUGHTER].
Yeah. That way?
All right cool. Great thank you.
[NOISE]
Oh wow! Great. Right. You're answering quickly.
Another like 20 seconds if that's enough time to give the answers.
[NOISE]
All right cool.
Um, that's fascinating.
There's a lot of disagreement in this class.
Um, people must say why,
why would you choose option one,
why would you option two?
And then I- I- I- I- I have a very strong point of view on what I would do, right?
Um, but, but I'm curious why,
uh, why option one and why option two. Go ahead.
Option one is easy to debug in the environment.
Easy to debug. Anything else? Either option one or option two?
Option one is simple.
Option one is simple. Anything else?
Option two is not an environment.
Option two is not the environment. [LAUGHTER].
I was thinking the option one, right?
If you've a dog in your house and he barks and it can activate.
So, when you have option two,
you can probably kind of already like simplify the problem but it does not,
is another way to I mean,
activates the machine but doesn't by itself.
[NOISE] That's why if it's talking to.
Yeah, if the dog barking.
Option two, it would be much better.
Yeah, yeah, someth- something kinda goes noise.
Cool. All right. And just two of you and in each-.
Option two, they're making noise from people like whispering?
Like, what if someone is whispering?
Huh?
What if someone is whispering?
What if someone's whispering?
[inaudible].
Yeah, yeah, go. Yeah, go ahead, have you.
[inaudible]
I think it will pick up the background noise.
Yeah, cool, yeah. And in a noisy place like, you know,
I have a friend who's, uh,
lives actually listening to the train station.
So, right, so.
option one will cover a lot of things [NOISE],
which is possible. Yeah.
Whichever option you take has to be running constantly.
So, you want something that is very cheap,
so it seems like option one is better than [inaudible].
Yeah, whether we pick has to be constan- constantly somehow to be cheap,
low power, low conflict.
So, le- let me show you some of the pros and cons.
Um, uh, so, um,
uh, I think, yeah,
there are pros and cons in option one and option two was why there's so,
so, so many votes were both options.
I perceived we'll choose option one.
Um, but, but let me just,
let's just discuss the pros and cons, right?
I think that's, um, uh,
option one, um, forces just a few lines of codes.
Is, is yes, maybe options two isn't that complicated,
but option one is even simpler.
And I think that, um, uh,
actually maybe I would say if I hadn't worked on
this problem before I will choose option one.
Uh, but since I have experience in
speech recognition eventually I know you need option two.
But that's because I, I because I've worked on this problem before.
But if it's your first time working on the speech activation problem,
I would encourage you on average to try
to really simple quick and direct solutions and go ahead and,
um, so let's see how long would it take to implement this.
Right? I would say like 10 minutes,
five minutes, I don't know, right?
How long would it take to implement that?
i don't know. Like what?
Four hours? One day?
I, I, I don't really know actually.
Right. Um, le- let me just write one day,
I'm, I'm not quite sure.
Right, but if, um,
option one can be implemented in 10 minutes then I would encourage you to do that.
And go ahead and put the smart speaker in your home or in your potential users homes.
And only when you find out that the dog barking
is a problem or the train on the railway station or whatever is a problem,
then go back and invest more in fixing it, right?
And, in fact, um,
It's true that maybe it's annoying if the dog barking keeps on waking up the system.
But maybe that's okay because if the large neural network then screens out
all the dog barking then the overall performance systems actually just fine.
And, uh, and, and,
and you now have a much simpler system.
Right? But, uh, but, but it,
it turns out that, um, the reason, uh,
you might need to go to option two eventually is
because there are some homes in noisy environments.
Uh, uh, you know, there's constant background noise,
and so that will keep the large neural network running a little bit too frequently,
so, so if you have a large engineering budget,
you know, so, so, some of the smart speaker teams
are over hundreds of engineers that are working on it.
So, if you have hundreds of engineers work on it,
totally option two will perform better.
But if your strap a startup team,
a scrappy startup team with few of you working on a class project, you know,
the evidence that you need that level of complexity is not that high,
and I would really do that first and,
and you start to gather evidence that you really should make the investment to build
more complex system before actually making the investments of days or,
e- er, and eventually I think this is one day to build your first prototype,
right, and then eventually you'll be,
you'll be more complicated.
Um, it turns out that, um,
the other reason [NOISE] ,
um, the other huge advantage of the simple method is the following.
Um, and this is one of the frankly,
this is one of the, this is actually one of the big problems and
big weaknesses of Machine Learning algorithms in deep learning algorithms,
which is what happens is, uh,
um, when you build a system and you ship,
ship a product, the data will change, right,
and so, um, I'm gonna simplify the example a little bit.
But, you know, I, I know Stanford is very cosmopolitan,
this Palo Alto is very cosmopolitan.
See, you collect data in this region,
you get accents from people all over the world,
right, because, because that's Stanford or that's Palo Alto.
But, but just to simplify the example a little bit, [NOISE] um,
let's say that you train [NOISE] on, uh, US accents,
right, uh, but you know,
for some reason, uh,
uh, when you ship a product,
maybe it sells really well in the UK and you start getting data
[NOISE] with a UK or with British accents.
Right? So, one of the biggest problems
you face in practical deployment of Machine Learning systems is that,
the data you train on is not gonna be the data you need to perform well on.
Um, and, and I'm gonna share with you some practical ideas for how to solve this,
but this is one of those practical realities
and practical weaknesses of Machine Learning,
That is actually not talked about much in academia, uh,
uh because it turns out that the data sets we have in academia are
not set up well for researchers to study and publish papers on this.
I think we can start new Machine Learning benchmarks in the future.
But there's one of those problems that is actually kind
of under appreciated in academic literature.
Uh, but that [NOISE] is a problem facing many,
many practical deployments of Machine Learning algorithms.
Um, and, uh, and so,
more generally, the problem is one of data changing, right, and, uh,
you might have new classes of users with new accents or you might train a lot on,
uh, the, maybe you get data from
even Stanford users and maybe Stanford is not too noisy or Stanford has a certain,
you know, types of characteristics.
When you ship it to another city or another country that's much more noisy,
uh, you know, different background noise.
[NOISE] Right? Or, uh,
you start manufacturing the smart speaker and to lower the costs of the speaker,
they swap it out,
they swap out the high-end microphone that you use from your laptop to collect the data,
for a lower-end microphone, [NOISE] right?
It's very common thing done in,
you know, well, done in manufacturing, right?
If you could use a cheaper microphone why not, right, and,
and often to human ears,
The sound sounds just fine on a cheaper microphone,
but if you train your learning algorithm using your,
you know, I guess yeah, well,
I use a Mac, but a Mac has a pretty decent microphones.
If you train the data using all you collect from a Mac
and then eventually has a different microphone,
it may not generalize well.
So, one of the challenges of, um,
Machine Learning is that you often develop a system on one data set,
and then when you ship a product,
something about the world changes, uh, and, and,
and your system needs to perform on
a very different type [NOISE] of data than what you had trained on.
Um, and so, [NOISE], Um, and so,
what will happen is after you deploy the model, uh,
the world may change and you often end up going back to get more data,
redesign the model right and,
and, and I guess, er, and this is,
this is, uh, uh, the maintenance of the Machine Learning model.
Uh, I wanna give some other examples.
A web search, right,
uh, this happens all the time,
at multiple web search engine which is, uh,
you train a neural network or you train a system to,
to give relevant web search results.
But then something about the world changes.
You know, for example there's a major political event,
some new person is elected president of some foreign country
or there's a major scandal or just the Internet changes,
right, or, or there's a, a, a, actually what,
what happens in China is that new words getting invented all the time.
Uh, uh, in, in, in Chin- the Chin- uh,
says that, by of what they Google and Baidu,
but the Chinese language is more fluid than the English language,
and so new worst get invented all the time.
And so, the language changes,
and so whether we are trained just isn't working as long as it used to, right.
Um, or, or, or maybe a different company,
suddenly shuts off, you know,
their entire website to your search index because they don't want you, uh,
indexing their website and so it's like
the Internet changes and what have you done doesn't work anymore.
Um, or, um, uh, self-driving.
Okay. [NOISE]. Uh, it turns out that you build a self-driving car in California,
and then you try to deploy these vehicles in Texas, um, you know,
it turns out traffic lights and Texas look
very different than traffic lights in, in, in California.
So, a model trained on California, Texas on,
so a neural network trained to recognize, uh,
California traffic lights actually doesn't work very well on Texas traffic lights.
Right? Uh, I'm trying to remember which way around to this,
but I think California and Texas have
a different distribution of horizontal versus vertical traffic lights for example,
there's actually, as humans don't notice as you go,
oh yeah, red, yellow, green,
but the learning algorithm doesn't actually generalize
that well if you go to a different location.
You've go to a foreign country, again, traffic lights,
signage, the lane markings all change, um.
Or I guess, well,
one example I was working on earlier this week, right?
Uh, manufacturing, right, landing AI,
working on inspection of parts in factories, um,
and so if you are doing visual inspection [NOISE] in the factory,
and the factory starts making a new component,
you know, they were making this model of cell phone,
but cell phones turn over quickly, and so,
but in a few months later they're making a different type of cell phone or something
weird happens in the manufacturing process or
the lighting changes and new type of defect.
So the world changes, right?
And, um, so, oh, she got locked again?
[NOISE] What I'd like to do is, um,
actually revisit the previous question in light of this,
uh, the world changes, phenomenon, right?
[NOISE] Which is, let's say you've collected a lot of
data with American accented speakers.
Um, and then, you know, we'll ship the product to the UK.
And then, um,
and then for some reason you find that you have all these British accent speakers,
right, trying to use your smart speaker.
So, between these two algorithms,
the non machine-learning approach,
which is a set the threshold versus trained in neural network.
Which system do you think will be more robust for VAD, voice activity detection?
[NOISE]
All right, let's take like another,
I don't know, 40 seconds?
[NOISE]
All right. Yeah. Interesting. Do people want to comment?
Well, more, more, more people voted for a non-ML.
Does  someone want to explain why. Yeah. Go ahead.
[inaudible]
Yeah.
You're right. So we say,
for the VAD voice-activated section, uh,
if you just measure the volume,
then it doesn't really depend on,
on the absolute, right?
So, non ML might be more robust.
Anyone else? [NOISE]. All right.
So, again I'm going to show you about.
So, it turns out that, um,
if you train a small neural network,
uh, to, um, uh, you know,
American accented speech, uh,
there's a bigger chance,
that your neural network,
because it's so clever, right?
They'll learn to recognize American speech,
[NOISE] and have a harder time generalizing to British accented speech. Do I make sense?
And so, one of the things that I've seen a lot of teams,
uh, where-where's, so, so,
one way that non ML thing could fail to generalize,
would be that British speakers are systematically,
you know, louder or softer than American speakers, right?
So, you know, I know. I don't know if
Americans stereo typically are louder or less loud than British,
but, but, you know, but if, but if American and British speakers one,
one country just has louder voices as softer voices,
there maybe, the threshold you set won't generalize well,
but that seems unlikely.
I, I don't see that being realistically.
But, um, but if you train your neural network a lot, parameters, then, uh,
it's more likely that the neural network will pick up
on some idiosyncrasy of American accents,
to decide the [NOISE] salaries even speaking, um,
and thus maybe less robust in generalizing into British accented speech, right?
And, another way to think about this,
is if you imagine to take it even further example,
imagine that, um, you're using VAD for
a totally different language than, than English, right?
Where, um, take a different language, you know,
Chinese or Hindi or Spanish or something where the sounds are really different.
If you train a VAD system to detect, you know, English,
it may not allow work for detecting Spanish or Chinese or French or,
or some other language.
Um. And so, do you think of British accents as uh,
as somewhere on the spectrum.
Not a foreign language by any means,
but just more different,
than, I think the,
um, non ML system is, is,
is more likely to be robust, right?
And so, one of the lessons that too many, that,
that a lot of machine learning teams learn the hard way is uh,
um, if you don't need to use a learning algorithm for something,
if you can hand code a simple rule, like,
if volume greater than 0.01,
do this or that, uh, those rules are can more robust.
Um, and, the, one of the reasons we
use learning algorithms is when we can't hand code something, like,
I don't know how to hand code something to detect a cat,
or detect the car on the road,
or detect the person.
So, use learning algorithms with those.
But if there is such an encoded rule,
that actually does pretty well,
you find that it is more robust to shift into data and will often generalize better.
And uh, if any of you take a, uh, uh,
we talk a bit this,
about this little bit in CS 229,
I think CS 229 talks about this as well,
but this particular observation is backed up by very rigorous learning theory.
And the learning theory,
is basically that the fewer parameters you have, uh,
if you still do well on your training set.
If you can have model with very few parameters,
that does well on your training set,
you would generalize better, right.
So, there's this very rigorous machine learning theory that basically says that,
and in the case of the non machine-learning approach there's
maybe one parameter which is what's the threshold for epsilon.
And that's worked well enough for your training set,
then you are severe generalizing even when the data changes is,
um, much higher, right?
Um.
Now, the last question,
um, I want to pose for discussion today is, um,
when when discussing deployments, uh, oh, and,
and so, one of the lessons of deployment is,
that's just the way the world works.
Yeah. Pretty machinery system deployed,
the world will usually change and you often end up collecting
data and having integrated and maybe improve the model, right?
And you have fixed a model for British speakers around you.
Um. So, we talked about edge deployments,
as well as cloud deployments, right?
And so, um, ignoring issues of user privacy and latency,
which are super important,
but for purposes of question let's, let's,
let's put aside issues of user privacy and network latency.
Um, if you need to maintain the model,
so it means there's means of updating the model, right?
Even as the world changes.
[NOISE]. Um, oh sorry I miss, I miss typed.
It should read, does a cloud or edge deployment make maintenance easier, not of, right?
Uh, once you, once you just enter a one word answer, and, and why?
[NOISE] And so, maintenance is when the world changes, something changes.
So you need to update the learning model to take
advant- take care of this British accent.
So, which type of deployment makes it easier?
Let's take like, yeah, another two minutes to enter your answers.
[NOISE]
All right. Another like 50 seconds.
All right. Cool. Now, see what people wrote.
[NOISE] Wow.
Cool. Great. All right.
Almost everyone is saying Clouds.
Most people are saying cloud.
Almost. All right.
Cool. Great. And, and just to summarize,
I think there are actually two reasons why.
Most people said it's easier to push updates, that's part of it.
I think the other part of it,
is that if all the data that is at the edge.
If all the data is processed, you know,
in the user's home and another constant cloud,
then even if you have all of these unhappy British accents it uses,
you may not even find out, right?
You're sitting in the company headquarters,
you have all these users and mysterious things, you know,
seem to be not using your device maybe because they're unsatisfied with it,
but if the data isn't coming into your servers in the cloud,
then you might not even find anything about it.
Now, there's serious issues about user privacy,
uh, uh, as well as security, right?
So, so, so, please if you haven't bought the product,
please be respectful of that, uh,
uh and then take, take,
take care of that in a very thoughtful and respectful way of users.
But um, [NOISE] if, uh,
first if, um, so this is the cloud, right?
If you have a lot of edge devices and all the data is processed there.
Um, you won't even know what your users are doing.
And they're happy or unhappy. You just don't know.
But, if some of the data in a stream to your servers in the cloud,
and if the user privacy with
really fiscious good user consent tells you for what you're doing with the data,
but if you take care of that in a, in a, in a, in a,
in a reasonable and sound way,
if you're able to examine some of the data,
then you can at least figure out that gee looks like analyzing the data,
there are these people at this axon,
there's background noise that, um,
uh is uh, giving it bad product experience and you can also maybe have the data,
so you can gather the data from the edge,
to feed back to your model, right?
So, so it let's you detect that something's gone wrong,
um, unless you have the data to retrain the model,
so solve that British accent problem,
we can retrain the model for more British accented speech,
and then finally let's you push the model back up.
All right. So, [NOISE] first, it let's you detect what's going on, two,
it gives you data for training,
and three, unless you more easily push the model backup.
Uh, push, push, push the new model to production, to deployment, okay?
Um, and this is also why, uh,
even if your computation needs to run on the edge.
If um, you could in a way
respectful of user privacy and it's transparent at the how you use data,
if you can get even a small sample of data,
or have a few volunteer users send you some data back to the cloud,
that will greatly increase your ability to detect there's something's gone wrong,
as well as maybe give you some data to retrain the model.
Uh, so even if you can only do,
so that push updates, right, this, this will,
this will help greatly,
okay? Um. All right.
So, finally, one last comment I think uh, one, one,
one last challenge is uh,
in a lot of machine learning systems,
you're not done at deployment.
There's a constant ongoing maintenance process.
And I think, one of the processes, uh, you know,
AI teams are getting better and as well, setting up QA,
to make sure that we update the model,
you don't break something.
So I think, QA and large companies,
quality assurance processes is kind of testers.
And I think the way you test machine [NOISE] learning algorithms is
different in the way you test traditional software,
because the performance of machine learning algorithms is
often measured in a statistical way, right?
So it doesn't work and it doesn't work.
It, it, it neither works nor doesn't work.
Instead it works, you know, 95% of the time or something, and so,
lot of companies are evolving the QA processes to have
this type of statistical testing to make sure that even if you change the model,
you do a push update,
it still works, you know,
95 or 99% of the time or something rather than so,
so, so putting in place new QA test processes as well.
Okay? All right.
Hope that was helpful stepping through what
the full arc of a machine learning project will look like.
Uh,will, will later this quarter or in course three as well as in later,
lectures are present, [NOISE] we'll keep talking about
machine learning strategy and how they make decisions things.
So, let's break for today.